vous avez un admirateur secret il ya un
invité mystère ce soit puisqu'on est une
surprise pour vous derrière le rideau il
ya une personne que vous connaissez
avec qui vous avez travaillé il ya
quelques années sur la chaîne comédie
est ce que vous pensez à quelqu'un je
travaille avec un garçon qui est devenu
un très bon ami et avec qui j'ai entamé
une relation amicale qui s'appelle
franck
alors est-ce que c'est lui qui est mon
âme franck non la france
non ce n'est pas franck alors peut-être
que si vous entendez sa voix ça peut
vous aider
invité mystère ce que vous avez vu ce
qu'on pouvait dire bonjour à julien
bonjour je suis là bonjour invité
mystère est ce que cette voie vous dit
quelque chose
non invitées mystère
vous étiez à comédie avec julia vignali
c'est ça
vous étiez très proche ouais quel est
votre prénom
je suis michael michael michael c'était
quelle année michael parce que là c'est
un enfant je dirais ouais les gars il ya
20 ans 99 2000
c'est ça c'est ça oui c'était râpé d'un
michael ou pas pas du tout gagné moins
de poissons rouges ces séjours de coûter
c'est votre admirateur secret je propose
qu'on attende pas plus longtemps
michael l'admirateur secret qui
travaillent avec moi comédie j'étais je
crois que j'étais pas encore arrivé
d'accord voilà je suis pas encore là
pour lui ce soir se capter la wii se
connaissaient pas encore à l'époque
michael est avec nos applaudissements
pour michael
[Applaudissements]
à
ces rappels de michael ou pas michel
s'est tu bon ça fait combien de temps
que tu as pas revu non ça fait longtemps
est enfin vois ça fait 20 ans dit devant
et était vraiment qui m'admirent est
vraiment bah ouais j'ai en fait j'étais
ingé-son et voilà bon qu'on a et j'ai
son dallage sont intimidés par ce
dernier
donc
et donc voilà je te mettais les micros
et et à ce moment là j'ai senti quelque
chose quoi des deux côtés de détient pas
déjà de mon côté pour moi il y avait un
truc réciproque ans si tu penses quoi
et écoute à l'époque j'étais j'étais
célibataire ce qui est plus le cas donc
en fait ce qui est dommage oui voilà
maintenant c'est peut-être de l'amitié
voilà ce que je suis pas jaloux un truc
à dire à julia bat déjà que je la suis
depuis des années enfin voilà la pch qui
a fait tu vas démons admirateur secret
tu aurais je regarde je passe ce soir
c'est sûr ça c'est obligé quand je la
vois j'ai les larmes aux yeux la main je
trompe
et là franchement c'est nickel un
poisson d'avril
non non vraiment bras c'est vrai oui
mais si
j'écris ce n'est pas un poisson d'avril
à lennon fasse un peu quand même mais
voilà je voulais te faire un cadeau
ouais en fait je voulais te demandé de
m'épouser quoi le retour
servez nickel sans rigoler ici non c'est
pas une blague c'est sincère qui
transpire prince michael alors faut que
je te dise quelque chose je ne suis pas
célibataire et j'ai pris un mauvais prix
qu'est ce que la fidélité et je ne peux
pas du tout déroger à cette règle la
même une fronde en forme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si je divague alors moi ce que je dis
aux admirateurs secrets qui n'ont pas la
réponse qu'ils le veulent sur l'émission
c'est grâce à ce que je ne te dire tu
vas pouvoir passer à autre chose et
cette bague tu vas lui offrira une femme
célibataire qui tu admires autant que tu
admires et c'est tout le mal que je te
souhaite
bravo il est premier rang duquel alors
on se tire un peu déçu michael va julia
oui est ce que tu peux faire quand même
un petit bisou michael tu va nous
refaire une vision à versailles
je voudrais pas non plus donné de nom ce
juste un groupe merci michael pas trop
déçu michael bay un peu quand même
à chauny ici j'avais acheté la bague
exprès ouais j'ai acheté un bagel racing
et tu peux la voir
je sais pas c'est pas et elle est
magnifique et attendez je vous la montre
michael litres et julia vignali est ce
qu'on peut me redonner la date
d'aujourd'hui
elle date de notre rencontre avec une
dent aujourd'hui la date le 1er avril
date de suite un poisson d'avril
[Applaudissements]